only because I want joncarnage to tell
me about this Icelandic incest app yeah
explain it's an incest prevention app
Yeah right there's an app yeah that
people get before they make love yeah
and they put their names into it and
then it tells you if they're related or
not now that's what I was told when I
was in Iceland because I sins like
tonight land it's only certain my
population okay I'm also from an island
which only has a certain right all right
right guys just don't give a [ __ ] you
know you don't care that's what it is
all right you see all right all right
double switch don't look straight let's
just play for that can of worms O'Dwyer
and why were you hating on this game did
you ever have a second CD man no but I
just want you to rile you up so that you
preached the Word of double switch hard
so here's the thing right that's one of
the quarries this port hey more Corey
Feldman okay one of those quarries right
like a quarry he's uh he's in the
basement he's telling you some stuff
like yo man yo this dude lock me down
here but you're a rad guy and I can
trust you so you should be able to go
and do some stuff there's security
things that are happening in this place
right now but I like you but before you
do that don't mess with any of the
people that live here okay that's it
that's exactly what he's saying he's a
queer friends right we're friends right
he had his hair bleach blonde so
inspired me to bleach my hair blonde too
when highways yeah this guy was awesome
mal Lost Boys the license to drive I
think there's another one oh yeah and
blondie or less blonde dear that's
blondie really one day her hair is black
yeah and then like so I need to figure
out how to move and he's telling you how
to like to get me look at the map in how
to play now I haven't played this in
like a little bit of time and so I'm
probably gonna fail a few times so that
guy right there he was also in Superman
remember this is like a star-studded
cast I can barely tell what that guy's
face looks like so good as i play this
game all the time so like she's walking
in her room right oh you stepped on that
thing when you step when you see like
bad dude step on that thing okay then oh
and that's the dude from a full metal
jacket that's the drill sergeant oh why
do you think I didn't like this game I'm
telling you the truth
like when the most star-studded games of
all time was that before or after night
trap this was before okay my trouble is
probably the wrong infamous of the FMV
games probably because of its violence
and weird so right now I'm gonna let
some of those people get past cuz you
have to protect her right so he's gonna
walk past this thing and then it's good
he's gonna watch it watch out you may
not you yo I'm mad I messed up I messed
up I didn't catch this dude uh you have
to watch these people so this is just
playing this is just you let's go
playing on its own there's a guy in here
are you flicking between the cameras as
well I'm flicking between the cameras
but the thing is that you have to catch
a certain amount of people so you have
to have a ratio a really good ratio so
you can't get too caught up in the
storylines because every time you get
caught up in storyline a dude comes in
and like turns off your power right here
I know the song you want to sing it with
me sure see how you fly see you the moon
ya know we have to catch this guy real
quick see what I mean I'm gonna [ __ ]
see what's going on dichotomy you got it
it's like Shawn Michaels goodnight avid
Shawn Michaels and I wasn't huh Shawn
bike yeah see you lose yeah can you just
stay here and watch this you lose the
game but if you do that you are in
trouble because he'll turn you off this
game is really hard so anybody who's
like playing supple uncle on the back I
want you to try to play a double switch
brother laying down the gauntlet seeing
with me I fell all the [ __ ] realize
nobody made kick started a new FMV game
is that what this text mokey wait Oh zoe
quinn working on a new fmd that is true
with somebody from the room did you hear
about that do it interesting there may
be some sort of greg cicero zoe quinn
collab or maybe it's it's tommy was oh
who knows so here's another part that
makes this game incredibly hard is that
you have to see these guys open up those
things in order to summon number five
so hot take that your son of a bit how
you see how fast you have to be is this
your speed run this is just ignoring you
knowing this all from like sense memory
look at you you know i gotta son this is
why you like that game after other
brother that was your big brother owes
me so here's the fun part like if you
hit one of the this guy you'll get
knocked back to cory here ok watch punch
it he doesn't like that you hit the
people that pay the rent into the place
what type of house is this this is
Brutus for see he pays the rent man but
you guys are like a maze about this and
you told me this is why would we play a
crappy game like double switch there's
no other game like this in the world the
Sega CD didn't exactly so very much it's
sold enough to me here you can do it to
him Saturday when you went from say got
the Sega CD were you just like so little
jazz blown away we just explain what the
Sega CD was to be look as I've just
realized i was a bit 8 years old when
this tank game at this was an expansion
pack it was an attachment on your
Genesis peripheral you slide on the side
of your Genesis it's a spinning CD drive
right you flip it up you put in the disc
and boom FMV hotness like not all the
games like through a sonic CD like that
was just a reg that wasn't an FM be
sonic game if it was people probably
would've bought the Sega CD like Heather
no man but no matter what would have
made people but like digital pictures
were just this one developer / hating V
house that just made loads of these best
name in the gaming business DP digital
pictures I wanted to work for them so
bad that's how to work with you get
through I think he might have gotten
through you might have shut me down
feeling pretty strong all right we're
good so if you have too many of those um
these traps set up you will overpower
like override your system and then
you'll like run out of power okay you
have to like make sure that you turn
them off you can't just have them all
set up to go obviously they have to
maintain it makes so much sense when I'm
explaining here here we go let's get him
he's in turn back around how much of
your
suffering get him did you have to go to
understand how that game worth is like
this is the greatest thing ever like a
real extensive instruction manual or
something or no no no that [ __ ] does a
kid the instruction manual is called
failing over and over and over again and
then eventually just going and I I I
gotta beat this he's gonna step on the
mummy right here ah and then you have to
just like move on you can't even watch
these awesome traps and stuff happen so
this is like a real intense part right
here because they're gonna kill or try
to kill one of the guys that lives in
your pool are these people and why is
this happening don't know to this day is
this oh no you see what happened no I
told you we got power overload Corey's
not happy we're all done we're doomed
you're all doomed is that it game over
high score of course I could I ask or it
feels great put your name it I don't
know how to spell my name after getting
knocked in my head by goddamn books or
something jjjjjj there you go started
dawning Jays thank you so much why not
read of all is that was historical I
really appreciate that night my pressure
I used to be able to speedrun that for
real I used to actually be able to beat
that is there multiple ways you can win
it cuz after you know there's not
multiple cores know there's one way of
doing it you have to hurt you have to
survive by shutting off the people that
are trying to turn off your power yeah
you have to then keep your people live
that live in the hotel right because
we're gonna hotel right alright so then
you also have to give its code is you
got to get the codes there's codes in
those boxes you have to get them all yep
but then at the same time you have to
keep a ratio of like people that you
caught versus people that have escaped
right and I don't know if you saw but I
was not everyone is it cut I mean I need
to maintain some sort of mouse exact
hotel goes out of business right exactly
how you should just kind of know what
he's talking about yeah must collect all
the good people then the boppy but I
just stuck up there it's hard game okay
right so everybody who's like yeah man
just meet super meat boy play double
switch plate double sway with Sega sanam
is always thought of as it is the like
precursor to that era Saturn was there
basically their fix
after the CD sort of failed when you
look like your time of the sale what did
what here in this game made you think
that that was failure if you guys are
blown away surely creatively a massive
clearly no cause you're using massive
success okay hey not so much when you
look at my pictures SED time right you
think look back fondly yeah yeah what
are good games double switch is that's
one of them corpse killers another
franchise game ran sonic CD everybody
would be like yo that games awesome
soundtrack is brilliant and then we
start Stewart shark super shark you had
a good one we've got bogeys at 369 or an
eternal blue lunar eternal blue
everybody would agree that that's a good
game aiming game it's you guys who
doesn't that's the thing it sounds like
he's naming poor you guys never his
naming lady movies are poor lunar blue
that's a baby turn out or not you played
lunar you play lunar now working design
our games go to 11 joncarnage I'm
sitting here at this I'm in the game so
much but office you guys know what I'm
talking about should have this should be
a weekly feature we should get you on
every day to educate us about the
wonderful a great first
you